وها هي تاثيرات الحرب في اوكرانيا تصل
للقطب الشمالي المتجمد مع قلق من محاولات
روسيا والصين زياده نفوذهما في المنطقه
مجلس القطب الشمالي قطع العلاقات مع روسيا
العضو في المجلس ما يزيد خطر وجود منطقه
قطبيه دون قواعد خاصه اذا انشات روسيا
والصين مجلسا موازيا خاصا بهما للقطب
الشمالي المجلس يضم في عضويته اضافه
لروسيا كلا من الولايات المتحده كندا
ايسلندا ان روج السويد فنلندا والدنمارك
التي تتبع لها جزيره اركنلندا لكن بعيدا
عن الجانب السياسي لنتحدث عن الاهميه
الاقتصاديه للقطب الشمالي هذه المنطقه رغم
انها متجمده الا انها تصنف بانها الاكثر
ارتفاعا في درجات الحراره في العالم ويفتح
الباب وراء الاهتمام بمواردها وايضا بث
الموارد غير المكتشفه تقدر بتريليونات
الدولارات فهناك
30% من الاحتياط العالمي للغاز وخمسه عشر
في المئه من احتياط النفط غير المكتشف
عالميا اضافه لكميات كبيره من الالماس
ونيكل والزنك وعناصر نادره تدخل في
الصناعات العسكريه وخلال العقود الاربعه
الماضيه تقلصت مساحه الجليد في هذا القطب
بنسبه 55 في المئه ويتوقع العلماء ان
يخلوا القطب من الجليد بحلول عام 2050 بحد
اقصى طبعا ذوبان الجليد سيكشف عن ممرات
مائيه للشحن البحري تختصر المسافات بين
قارات اسيا واوروبا وايضا امريكا الشماليه
كما ان الذوبان سيجعل عمليات التنقيب
ممكنه وهنا يطرح التساؤل من له الحق
باستغلال موارد القطب الشمالي طبعا الدول
المطله على هذا القطب لها قانونيا حق
الاستغلال الاقتصادي للمنطقه الخاصه بها
وهي دول المجلس القطبي الا ان الاجزاء
الاخرى البعيده في القطب فلا ملكيه ولا
سياده لاحد عليها نختم من حيث بدانا ما
غياب الملكيه والسياده ونضيف اليهما غياب
القواعد ربما تكون هذه النقطه
المتجمده احدى اسخن بؤر التوتر في العالم
مستقبله لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات